first and foremost want to express the
thanks
for the people of the united states to
you mr president on behalf of our
president joe biden and to the people of
poland
for what you are doing every day
it really represents the best of who we
are
we are here and i am here in poland
today
as part of an enduring long-standing
friendship and commitment between the
united states and poland based on shared
values
and priorities
i am here
standing
here on the northern flank on the
eastern flank talking about what we have
in terms of the eastern flank and our
nato allies and what is at stake at this
very moment
what is at stake this very moment
are some of the guiding principles
around the nato alliance and in
particular
the issue and the importance of
defending
sovereignty and territorial integrity in
this case of ukraine
as president duda has described we have
been witnessing for weeks and certainly
just in the last 24 hours
atrocities of unimaginable proportion
a maternity hospital a children's
hospital
where we have witnessed pregnant women
who were there for care
for one reason
being taken out
because they required care because of an
act of violence
unprovoked
unjustified
i am here in poland
as an expression
of the
enduring and important relationship
between the united states and poland
that again has been long-standing but in
particular on the issue of ukraine
is unified and is clear
we will do everything together
in partnership in solidarity
to support what is necessary at this
very moment
in terms of the humanitarian and
security needs
of ukraine and the ukrainian people
today we discussed mr president many
issues
that relate to our special bond also
because i will say as a point of
personal privilege
we have a substantial polish-american
community
in my hometown of los angeles but
throughout the united states
who understands the relationship that we
have on many levels including the
diplomatic but also cultural
relationships that span generations
and so through
all of that and in the spirit of those
relationships and our shared commitments
our shared commitment to the importance
of international norms and rules
you and i discussed today many important
topics in particular as it relates to
the eastern flank
and we talked specifically about what we
care deeply about in terms of our
commitment the united states commitment
to article five
i've said it many times i will say it
again
the united states commitment to article
five is ironclad
the united states is prepared to defend
every inch of nato territory
the united states takes seriously
that an attack against one is an attack
against all
we are here today
to restate that commitment
but also to do what we must do to
reinforce
our support of poland
and our allies
through the eu and nato alliance in
particular as it relates to troop
deployment
we have recently deployed an additional
4 700 american troops to poland
that's on top of the years of rotation
of about 5 000 american troops in poland
we are pleased to have announced this
week that we have directed to patriot
missile defense systems to poland and
today i can announce that we have
delivered
those patriot systems to poland
we do this as a reminder and as a
demonstration of our commitment to the
security of our allies and our
commitment in particular to poland at
this moment in time
as it relates to the people
of ukraine
they have suffered immensely
when we talk about humanitarian aid
it is because yes the assistance is
necessary but what compels us also is
the moral outrage
that all civilized nations feel when we
look at what is happening to innocent
men women children grandmothers
grandfathers
who are fleeing everything
they've known
our outrage which compels not only our
security assistance but our humanitarian
assistance
is rooted in the fact
that also we support
the people of ukraine who have shown
extraordinary courage
and skill
and their willingness and yes ability
to fight against
putin's war
and russia's
aggression
so today we are also announcing in
pursuit of what must happen which is to
provide humanitarian assistance
that we will give another 50 billion
dollars the united states will through
the un's wood
world food program
to assist with humanitarian aid the
president and i also talked about the
fact that as he mentioned
poland has taken in just a very short
period of time in excess of one and a
half
million refugees in from ukraine
and that has put an extraordinary burden
on poland and the people of poland and
so we will continue
with the support that we can give you mr
president
in terms of the work that you and the
people of poland have been doing
to bear
this burden but in a way that really has
been with such grace
and such generosity
we also are pleased to have shared with
the president what
our united states congress has done
which is there is a commitment now
of 13.6 billion dollars
in human
humanitarian and security assistance
that will be
then distributed and shared with ukraine
and the people of this region and europe
all again understanding that this moment
in time requires both a humanitarian
response as well as security assistance
and today i'm also
pleased to say that we are
in ongoing discussions with poland and
our allies about the effectiveness of
sanctions thus far and going forward
as we have announced in the united
states
we have through the united states
department of justice
started a task force
to do what is required and necessary and
appropriate in terms of investigations
as it relates to any criminal activities
and behaviors
on behalf of institutions and
individuals including oligarchs
we talked to the president and i about
the effectiveness of the sanctions we've
seen thus far
in terms of the courage and the bold
action that has been taken
through the nato alliance
to do
what is necessary to send a clear signal
that there will be as we promised severe
cost and consequence
for russia's aggression
to the point that we have now seen
a freefall of the ruble
to the point that we have now seen that
russia's credit rating has been rated as
junk
and what we know to be
real economic consequence to russia
because of putin's war
as you know the president of the united
states also made the decision
to do what was necessary in terms of the
purchase of russian oil in the united
states again
we will continue
to focus on this issue
keeping in mind that this is a moment
that requires severe and swift
consequence
for russia's aggression against ukraine
and i'll close by saying what we say
every day
for these last weeks which is we stand
with the people of ukraine
that we admire their courage
and that we are aligned in our support
of their
sovereignty and territorial integrity
thank you mr president